ladies and gentlemen Donald Trump is an
authoritarian dictator who has just
assigned an executive order
here the serf listen to this the
authoritarian madman has signed an
executive order to commercialize the
solar system and mind on the moon I'm
kidding I'm he signed an executive order
but I don't think it's you know even if
it was a decree it's actually kind of
cool it's not gonna hurt anybody it's
gonna be fun
it's not really surprising but you know
what you know I'm curious about moon
mining like what if we're gonna we're
gonna mine on the moon and bring it
stuff back right right we're like
reclaiming the moon it used to be a part
of earth it got like blown off by like a
fixed collision supposedly there there's
it's actually in there you know what
they don't know exactly where the moon
is formed
why don't there's three different
theories that they're toying with why
don't we just take a cable we could talk
about that we should just take a cable
right mhm mm and hook it you know just
like hook it to a you know a hitch on
earth and then you know go up to the
moon and hook it to which in the moon
you know why that wouldn't work we'll
crank it in you know why that wouldn't
work because they would slow the
rotation of Earth down to a stop and we
would stop turning if we pulled the moon
and earth the drag of having they
thought about like you know space
elevators yeah or like someone wanted to
do like a tether to like a satellite
something and that the research showed
that eventually it would it would affect
the rotation of earth so if we were to
hook the moon up well how it would just
like halt us and we would stop I wasn't
I wasn't gonna say just stop I was gonna
say crank it in you know once get the
cable and you can start oh bring it
closer
yes Ben in the crank and then why mine
the moon just bring the moon here well
technically it's in it's in a perfect
orbit around us so if it gets closer
it's actually moving further away from
us out yeah but if it were to get closer
eventually it would fall and connect
with us and that would be good well be
bad back to the fund Donald Trump did in
fact sign an executive order yep they
say I love when they do these narratives
I mean you know honest I can't stand it
I can yell orange drunk captivated the
world when he took one giant leap onto
the moon's surface moons dusty service
in 1969 yes we know this it has nothing
to with the news present Donald Trump
who began his foray into galactic
affairs when he championed the space
force to fight extraterrestrial Wars
the extra-terrestrial do you know what
terrestrial means are you kidding me it
would be the Mars force you morons Trump
did not sir a space force to fight on
other planets extraterrestrial means
other planets who are these people
no I don't know but I don't like their
article very much Wow
it's a great start to fight
extraterrestrial Wars is looking for his
own moon landing moment I am I am
angered but my minor dumb is furious at
their improper articulation in the midst
of the corona virus pandemic the White
House announced Monday an executive
order in which Trump calls for us
business interests to mind the moon I
love that that's it it's like Trump
hereby decrees by executive order if you
had a business go mind the moon okay
let's get started
only to rock it a couple of them yeah
though the order specifies whatever that
a return to the moon would allow the
country to explore and exploit lunar
minerals it insinuates the scope of this
new era of commercialization would apply
to the moon Mars and other celestial
bodies okay now that's extraterrestrial
lunar development would include a search
for minerals as well as water and this
would require partnerships between the
US government and private industry what
else is new according to the order one
of the major roadblocks holding
businesses back from mining the moon is
uncertainty regarding the right to
recover and use space resources
including the extension of the rights to
commercial recovery and use of lunar
resources Trump's executive order
attempts to advance the scarce legal
framework that governs various nations
claims to space several international
resolutions such as the moon agreement
have been adopted over the past 50 years
but the administration in its in its
order did not acknowledge the legitimacy
of these yeah in 1979 there was a
international treaty saying they
wouldn't mind planets or an American
never signed that treaty good and I you
know what if we're gonna go we have to
mine we we can't we we have to figure
out a way to make it self-sustaining and
if if there is water somewhere we have
to to get it you know order I told you
about that show Mars it's really
interesting how it parallels real life
because it is half
you memory so it talks about a lot of
this stuff and it it goes over the whole
science is going to discover stuff but
then private enterprise also goes and
they're mining and they don't care about
the treaties they're not in the treaties
and it's like this this treaty that they
were talking about is the countries that
are in the treaty but SpaceX can go if
they go out and land on Mars and they
they can start mining they're not part
of this treaty well that's I think I
think it's it's very likely that we're
gonna see colonization from private
entities absolutely no one can do
anything about absolutely it's it's
international waters out there
so what's no one owns xoan well Elon
Musk is Elon Musk is building this
really big spaceship to go to Mars right
he actually you know he personally told
me this okay yeah did he tell you
because I tweeted oh yeah I remember
this why aren't why aren't you building
an Iron Man suit he's like building
starship but I wonder if if Elon Musk
does this what what will it won't be a
country I gotta I gotta be honest man
companies function in a very
authoritarian manner like you can quit a
company so it's not like you know
they're Nazis or anything but the boss
is the boss you can't question the boss
they can kick you out you can't do
anything about it could you imagine
being on Mars as an employee of the you
know the corporation and then getting
fired not getting fired like you can't
get fired so they're probably never
regress testing and all that stuff
that's a good point but complaining I
think I need more food no you're okay
yeah the company controls everything
about your life yeah they're providing
you a place to live indentured servitude
on Mars well they have very strict
regiments of what they eat
astronauts but I do think honestly if
you volunteered to be like one of the
first missions to Mars you're probably
not coming back they're gonna treat you
like a king I agree it's like you you're
gonna you're gonna have the best the
best on every movie every video game
yeah man if yeah I'm sure the latency is
way too high it's probably what is the
latency to Mars like 20 minutes yeah I
think so you can't play any video games
with anybody you know it's really for a
better tech when we first went into
space astronauts were heroes they were
like everyone was like you're going
where no one's gone before you are
champion you are the champion human
and it's like no one really thinks about
astronauts like three astronauts flew
off earth this morning at 4 a.m. I don't
know if you guys knew this but they flew
off in in the Soyo sand connected with
the International Space Station and
that's so cool like I really I don't
know if you notice I'm really into space
stuff it's great but we don't we don't
champion them the way we used to and
it'll feel like it might be coming
around because you know there's a new
sense that we're gonna go out there
we're gonna go you you've seen
interstellar right mm-hmm
yeah we literally just watched this
because I think it was on before we did
the show yeah and there's that scene
where he goes to the school and the
teacher says we built useless machines
to pretend like we were gonna go places
we never went we never went to the moon
Global of law like that mentality is
actually becoming prominent when when
Elon Musk launched the car into space a
lot of people cheered and then a bunch
of activists condemned it saying he
wastes all this money why is he spending
billions of dollars go to space why
isn't he helping people here and then
people had to correct them and say you
realize he didn't spend the money on the
moon he spent it on people working on
the earth yeah to build things right and
then other people were like you realized
the purpose of sending the car into
space was to make something exciting and
fun that would inspire people right so
they would see this car in space which
is silly but then it would create a
moment that people would look look at
and be like wow that was when he
launched the Tesla with a guy in it
there was also a test payload you know
exactly so exactly
they had to put something in there and
they're not gonna put a human in there
and that's actually part of the reason
why we stopped editing space races
because the Challenger mission when we
lost all those astronauts it was
devastating for the public the public
didn't want people to die going into
space I mean it's it's inevitable and
there's gonna it's space it was not
earth did you hear that the Tesla car
missed what do you mean it's trajectory
was off
no I didn't know they're like whoops now
it's gonna drift off into space and then
come back and like a thousand years or
something really
yeah I can't Roberto supposted I was
reading an article about it where they
were like you know it's a good it's a
good thing it wasn't a real person
because now exactly
we're lerigot's and then i mean i
retweeted everyone's been asking Ilan de
to post the video of the Falcon landing
yeah and he did it
did you see the the debris tweet that I
tweeted now man it's so cool there's a
there's a video of just like attached to
the side of the rocket the rocket coming
back from space and landing on the wall
on the platform I watching that blows me
away it's so cool where and where we are
now and the government couldn't get it
done know it you know you know when the
US was competing with the Soviet Union
they got a lot done when they when the
US dominated with no competition they've
got to do anything they sit around on
their hands mm-hmm so let me ask you if
feelin must came a-knockin and said Adam
I want you to come in the rocket and be
the first person on Mars I wouldn't do
it you wouldn't do it no I thought about
this a lot actually and I don't it's not
that I don't want to go to Mars I would
like to go to Mars but I don't I don't
know it's an interesting question I mean
I I want to have a family here and I
want to be a part of my family and if if
I know what it would take to go to Mars
and I can't do that
I can't commit to that much time I was
reading that they actually only want to
send couples really yeah like one of the
things I was reading about Mars mission
was that a sense researchers said it has
to be couples because it helps sanity
right people will lose their minds if
they're isolated this way mm-hmm and in
close quarters coupling actually works a
lot better so and they'll end up having
kids and they'll establish themselves
there with their family and be less
reliant on social interaction from
strangers or anything like that and so I
was reading something like they actually
want like 10 couples so that there is a
mini community in society where people
are reliant there they have their social
structure they can raise a family and be
there permanently and then the plan
would be to slowly send supplies there
not leave you should see the show Mars
is it's really cool why are we doing
this where's the on must someone get me
Long's phone on this is happening a lot
is happening you know there there's this
whole thing that he just did that Trump
just did is because
we need to be able to mine the moon when
we set up the base there which is what
the Artemis program is what's when was
happening when did Artemis start I think
it started last year when he announced
it but I'm not really certain but I know
that their plan was to be on the moon by
2024 now it's been pushed back because
of kovat so now it's gonna be 2029 what
I know yeah where's that where's that
virus I'm gonna go show them what for
yeah please do would you please line up
our five-year right thank you Tim yeah
so we're gonna get to the moon mmm we're
gonna build like a moon port yep and
then we're gonna use that as a launching
base to go to Mars
it makes a lot of sense since the plan I
wonder if if is what's on the moon is it
Kate is there anything that we could use
for like refining a fuel of some sort
they say that in in the dust particles
they've found stuff that they can use I
don't have it pulled up right now but
yeah there is stuff out there I'm pretty
sure there's ice somewhere on the moon
yeah I'm not sure all we want to look
into it is invent replicators man
already done wouldn't it be great yeah I
mean a tea or a great hot yeah boom yeah
gallon of gas there you go go drive your
car around
dude I'm stoked I mean it's cool that
we're gonna see this in our lifetimes
well we're probably gonna be old dudes
watching you know in the virtual neural
link or whatever is out by then oh maybe
we'll get it what maybe we can download
the experience package like Total Recall
yeah like I was actually thinking about
neural link like if somebody's got a
neural link in their brain and it's
recording their experience and they go
to the Mars right and then they transmit
the experience data it's like you know a
50 terabyte file or something mm-hmm
they transmit it back to earth and you
can download it for like 20 bucks and
get the on going to Mars experience and
you just connect and then you like
experience everything what they felt
what they saw Total Recall yeah dude but
like you've seen that movie right yeah
of course yeah yeah the original one
going to Mars people are people are
popping up within the chat with helium-3
it's on the moon oh and yeah and so
interesting yeah yeah thanks Jeff
according to Futurama there were whalers
on the moon because you didn't know this
yes they carry a harp or Whalers on the
moon yes that song popped in my head
yeah yeah and then I love it when they
show the honeymooners and he's like one
of these days bang zoom straight to the
moon yeah and then Fry's life Lela goes
I didn't know you're astronauts were so
fat he's like that's not an astronaut he
wasn't talking about the going to the
moon he was using space travel as a
metaphor for beating his wife yeah I
love that [ __ ] agree thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you